sleeping on a plane is
hard especially if you're in an economy
seat
so we asked an expert for advice I'm an
occupational therapist industrial
designer and certified professional
ergonomist with seated sleep posture not
only do you fall into these awkward
postures but you're also compressing the
vertebrae in your spine at the different
levels you have to plan ahead here's
what a professional ergonomist
recommends for sleeping in an economy
plane seat
first you might consider using the tray
table but the position using the tray
table if you're propping up on your
forearms That Awkward positioning the
contact pressure against the tray table
all that's going to irritate tissue and
sleep just like it would during your
waking hours contact pressure happens
when soft tissues are pressed against a
hard surface for too long slowing blood
flow to your extremities and often
causing numbness or tingling with soft
tissue compression you can compromise
circulation you can impinge nerves which
can lead to numbness or tingling which
will often wake people up then there's
your posture it's going to be difficult
for you to maintain that posture very
long because you will be experiencing
excessive flexion at your hips and knees
your spine will be rounded you'll be
putting pressure through your forearms
dissolve there are both inflatable and
memory foam cushions available that
start to at least address some of those
risk factors such as the contact
pressure against the hard surface of the
tray table by by providing a soft
surface for your body to rest they can
hold your arms and then it also cradles
your head and neck and your face in a
way that attempts to at least position
your head and neck in some sort of a
neutral posture but depending on your
height and how far back the person in
front of you reclines the tray table
might not be your best option I think
it's probably going to serve you well
just for sort of a short stretch for a
nap I don't think you'll be getting the
highest quality of sleep in that
position so what about leaning back in
your seat if you have to sleep in an
economy class seat in a seated position
you are up against some challenges ideal
State your body would would prefer to
sleep in a fully supported lying down
position your body already has to endure
weight-bearing and force through your
spine your hips your pelvis your lower
extremities whenever it's sleeping
ideally it is great if you can steal a
couple degrees of recline from your seat
back just to put your body in a little
bit more of a supported sleep position
just be mindful of your neighbor
you can also adjust your back position
putting just a gentle cushion behind the
seat back to support the spine is
beneficial the more head and neck
support you can provide the better
chance you have at achieving some
restful sleep and here's where a travel
pillow comes in handy a lot of these
supports are not all created equal there
are the tried and true u-shaped neck
pillows you want to keep your head and
neck as neutral as possible against the
unfortunate barrier of gravity and
upright positioning a lot of the ones
that I like wrap around the neck and
have a support just so they don't shift
during sleep they can sort of provide
full neck support so not just forward
flexion but lateral flexion even some
extension it can hold your head in like
a comfortable yet supported position for
sleep and if you don't have a pillow as
a last resort you can try to make do
with layers of clothing I think thesis
here is that if you are in a scenario
where you have to sleep or you're flying
during evening hours you have to plan
ahead besides pillows and posture there
are a few other helpful tips for
sleeping on planes you might think about
limiting light exposure with an eye mask
or having layers or a blanket for
thermal Comfort noise canceling
headphones just to limit some of the
auditory stimulation on a plane when it
comes to picking between the aisle
middle and window seats there isn't one
best option for everyone it's going to
be a bit subjective in terms of what
people find most comfortable sleeping on
an airplane if you need to use the
bathroom or stretch frequently the aisle
might be your best option but it also
means you'll be woken up every time your
seat mates need to get out as well I
think if you can avoid the middle seat
that's probably the best advice
and while the window seat can provide
support just make sure to add a pillow
or piece of clothing as a cushion
importantly Flyers should find a
position that allows them to move around
a bit while they sleep like they
normally would in bed the body is built
to be dynamic and your body needs those
movement breaks in order to lubricate
joints to release muscle tension to
mitigate strain but for those people who
still really can't snooze mid-flight
it's always worth it to get an upgrade
foreign
[Music]